as a woman and somebody going into the
healthcare field how do you defend your
opinion as a white well-off religious
man telling a woman what she can do with
it because evil things are evil even if
i'm a white well-off religious man and
good things are so good even if i'm a
white
the reason being that the people who
were fighting against enslavement of
black people were a bunch of well-off
white men for the most part and those
people were saying this is a moral sin
this is a moral blot they weren't living
in the south they didn't own plantations
they didn't live the lives of the
plantation owners they said this is evil
and we are here to stop it i would
suggest that my identity has nothing to
do with what is right or wrong and this
is what western civilization used to be
about western civilization used to be
about the idea that yes i'm not a woman
in the healthcare field but you and i
can have a conversation about what's
right and wrong because this is the
nature of human reason i refuse to
surrender the idea that i can have a
moral stance on issues that are of
concern to society simply because of the
color of my skin or the nature of my
genitalia and honestly i believe any of
you that feels differently is sexist
racist and bigoted